next up in the news
a really interesting uh clip i saw i
actually started on pomp's podcast or
his live stream canadian professor and
youtuber jordan peterson
has been orange build uh and it's kind
of an interesting moment uh orange pill
is at moment in time because bitcoins i
guess official color like
this week in startups and launches is
orange uh and inside's my favorite color
it represents basically meaning you buy
into bitcoin and you're gonna have laser
eyes if you take the blue pill
that means you uh like fiat money debt
and you're blissfully ignorant so let's
roll the tape here from jordan peterson
if you don't know jordan peterson he's a
somewhat controversial he kind of got
bundled with the alt-right professor who
became famous because he got into an
argument with some woke students and uh
he really seems to care about young
males and has created a a bit of a
following with that reddit in-cell young
male crowd that is
kind of feels like they are
maybe
hated or told they're bad
and don't have a lot of uh let's call it
guidance in the world and this clip
comes from an interview he did with dr
sefedeen amus
uh seyfadin i hope i am pronouncing your
name correct sephidine is the author of
the bitcoin standard the decentralized
alternative to central banking which was
published in 2018. he's also a professor
at columbia university
yeah to get electricity from the north
of ontario to toronto re needs a lot of
wires or you need to you know if it was
gas you need to put it on tankers or on
trains or in pipelines all that stuff is
pretty expensive but with bitcoin you
just need an internet connection you
take the bitcoin miners to where that
energy is and then you can monetize that
energy and turn it into bitcoin it's
magic so what's the what's the net
effect of that on the price of
electricity worldwide is that
deflationary with regards to electricity
cost i think so i think this is this is
a point that i make in the fiat standard
which is that you know we've had fiat
subsidize all these dysfunctional forms
of energy over the last 50 years that
have led to the grid becoming unreliable
and we have bitcoin
like the vigilante savior that it is
coming in and providing a global subsidy
for anybody who can make electricity at
a cheap rate to monetize that that's
absolutely mind-boggling it'll take me
like five years to think that through
it's so s and it seems to completely
contradict the idea that bitcoin is a
waste of the world's resources it's a
complete opposite if that if this
monetization idea is actually true
all right so what you're having happen
there is this epiphany
uh with jordan peterson which of course
bitcoin people are gonna just
you know gonna be like yes you
understand it
what they're saying there is it starts
with
um this realization that well why would
you set up 350 000 in mining rigs to
mine bitcoin to get 350 000
if you just go on coinbase and buy it
you you would have had to wait for the
servers to come
set them up so all things being equal if
you could buy 350 000 worth of servers
and then turn it into
350 000 with a bitcoin eventually let's
assume you don't get the servers back
after that
in this bot experiment why wouldn't you
just buy it so it's like of course i
would but then it says wait but if you
can buy electricity cheaper which we all
know nuclear hydro if you're stealing
the energy like people were in
authoritarian places reportedly like
china people would roll these things up
to a hydro plant that was throwing off
more energy than it could actually send
through the cables or
some people talk about with natural gas
sometimes there's more you know gas
coming off of these pipes and gas
refineries and can actually be used but
they still have to burn it and so it's
kind of wasted and they need to ship it
somewhere that excess energy can be
turned into money okay that we all
understand but the next piece is wait a
second if i'm making energy and i can
make money from it and i don't have to
send it over a cable well
that's an incredible thing what that
doesn't take into account is should we
do that should we do that and the issue
there is we shouldn't waste energy in
other words we shouldn't build up
production certainly if it was dirty
energy gas coal uh anything like that we
should not be making bitcoin from dirty
energy i think everybody can agree with
that that's what's being left out of
this and the incentive obviously if you
can make money and not bother building
the cables to send it to somebody's home
or a factory where it's needed wow we're
destroying the environment we're burning
carbon and spewing you know uh all kinds
of horrible pollutants into the air
burning the ozone creating global
warming and destroying uh the ecosystem
just to make a quick buck so that's the
problem is we we haven't sort of put
that in here but let's play the next
clip why wouldn't they just buy bitcoin
it seems to be to be a lot simpler than
mining it then if it costs 350 000 to
make 350 000 why bother with the mining
the short answer is if you have a way of
securing electricity at less than five
cents per kilowatt hour then you should
get into bitcoin mining business which
is you know lower than most trades
everywhere in the world so if you have a
source of energy that is isolated from
the grid or if you have a cheap way of
securing energy then mining bitcoin is
great so does that mean that bitcoin is
a very good way of moving resources from
places that can produce electricity very
cheaply to other places where
electricity is more expensive it makes
the cheap electricity much more valuable
absolutely it's uh this is weird that's
a weird thing it's it's very weird i
think it's gonna have a very profound
impact on the global energy market
because for the first time in history we
have a way to sell energy that is
location independent a lot of places in
the world have a lot of energy but it's
very expensive to get that to the
population center so the north of canada
hasn't so you don't need wires
exactly jesus that's weird
the problem with this is i don't think
it is true we really do not want to
incentivize people to not send the
electricity to a city and instead just
burn it to make bitcoin to make money
because again we're burning natural
resources to do it the only time we
would really want to do this is if it
was a very low cost
natural uh source of energy like hydro
wind solar sure why not
monetize the excess there
and then use it for those folks to then
uh invest in more renewables and that is
the positive effect so what should
happen on a global basis is we should
ban bitcoin miners from using
non-renewable sources of energy perhaps
if this does become an acute issue
there's no way to know uh exactly what's
the total footprint of the energy usage
right now i know some people have tried
to make estimates about that we really
should think about either bitcoin has to
figure out a way
to
re-organize itself in other words do an
update
to use less energy i think they've tried
to do that uh over time and maybe they
have somebody can fact check me on that
producer's app this week in startups.com
if we ever get something wrong we'll
correct ourselves and we'd love to you
know get sources of good information so
there's a source of how much energy is
being used and the percentage of energy
being used
from non-renewable to renewables we
should just ban any bitcoin miners from
using coal
gas oil whatever is dirty because that's
not good for society bitcoin doesn't
provide enough value for society to use
that kind of uh non-renewables well with
renewables you know hey that's actually
pretty awesome and maybe this will drive
the price down if there is demand for
energy and bitcoin miners can figure out
how to use solar wind and they put some
of that money into actually creating
energy sources that's what i would love
to see
if it is in fact the future of society
that energy equals money
which is kind of what we're saying here
well then it would be pretty great for
somebody to come up with a fusion
reactor or a nuclear reactor or some you
know amazing new solar technology that
was super cheap to build and that we
could
in fact turn into money that then could
be put back into doing it i think by the
time this all gets hashed out maybe
bitcoin will use less energy
and we'll have renewable technology that
will continue to lower the cost uh per
gigawatt whatever so an interesting
moment in time i thought i'd share that
clip uh and again i've saw
hump was reacting to that person so just
give pomp a little credit for surfacing
for me he's uh anthony popliano's guess
he's 90 in bitcoin he's a maniac and
he's really interesting guy and we're
going to do a collaboration with uh my
guy pomp where we stream to his audience
on his youtube channel my audience on my
youtube channel hopefully the
subscribers cross over and we share some
audience together that's kind of the
idea i did with justin khan it was quite
fun actually because we got his audience
has certain questions my own ants asking
questions and then we answer them
together
when you are trying to grow a startup
fast hiring engineers will slow you down
like nothing else don't i know it so
many companies i invest in are telling
me they can't get their next version out
because they don't have a great engineer
well lemon.io will find you a perfect
candidate in just 48 hours it's a
marketplace of engineers from europe and
they test and interview every developer
to eliminate the risk of a failed
project lemonio is the perfect solution
if you are a technical co-founder and
you need to delegate some of your
important tasks or you have a project
that needs specific technology and you
don't have that skill on your team yet
or you are just growing so fast that you
need to add more developers and get more
done
faster they'll match you with a
candidate within 48 hours and if it
doesn't work out they'll replace the
developer right away so here is your cta
the old call to action if you could use
a full full-time or even part-time
developer to run your projects faster go
to lemon dot io slash twist once again
lemon l-e-m-o-n dot io
twist and you'll receive a 15 discount
for the first four weeks of work with
that amazing developer well done lemon
okay check it out everybody lemon dot io
slash twist